what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm your host
Warren Thompson and it looks like Marvel
Studios has quite a bit of special
presentations planned for us for the
Marvel Cinematic Universe now yes Marvel
Studios is going to start changing the
way that they do things regarding Disney
plus content we are going to talk about
how that could possibly affect the
special presentations but for the most
part we've noticed that they kind of sit
separately from the Disney plus actual
shows and Marvel Studios might have a
very specific purpose planned for the
special presentations one that could
very much help the future of the MCU as
we know it and today we're going to be
talking about five special presentations
that Marvel Studio has planned or had
planned and could possibly have been
scrapped due to the writer strikes and
just the whole restructuring of how
they're going to produce Disney plus
content but nonetheless the ones that
they do have planned are going to get
you super super excited because these
projects are going to be awesome so if
you love Marvel and want to stay up to
date be sure to subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest videos and
if you subscribe and leave a comment
down below you're automatically entered
in our giveaway for a chance to win an
Xbox series X A PS5 some Marvel Legends
items or some DC items as well the
winner gets to pick one item and we pick
a winner at the end of each month so
real quick we'll just address the fact
that Marvel Studios is probably going to
be cutting back on Disney Plus shows
some insiders have stated that we are
not going to be getting the same formula
that we've been getting recently with
the Disney Plus shows that means no more
Disney Plus shows that have six episodes
and have a 200 million dollar budget now
while some people could interpret this
as they are going to scrap Disney Plus
shows in general I don't think that's
the case I think they are simply going
to be cutting back in fact Marvel
Studios president Kevin feige has
confirmed that basically they are going
to cut back with how many shows they
make and the frequency in which they
release them so instead of doing four to
six shows a year like they have had
planned in the past but hasn't really
worked out due to things like the writer
strike and Etc but they're now probably
going to release one to two a year with
a special presentation thrown in the
middle there this is not too much if you
have three movies a year maybe four
movies a year and then one or two Disney
plus projects that's not bad that's not
too much work and that frequency is not
too much as well but you can give each
project the time and the attention that
they deserve and the budget that they
deserve these Disney Plus shows aren't
cheap and if you cut back on Disney Plus
shows then that budget can go elsewhere
but here's why the special presentations
are different than regular Disney plus
Marvel Studio shows with the Disney Plus
shows they have different purposes for
releasing them some serve a very
specific purpose and some just simply
want to introduce a character and not
really have an agenda at all thank
She-Hulk While others set up the MCU in
a really big way like one Division and
Loki while special presentations are
going to kind of serve as introductions
for very specific characters who could
appear in their own films later on or in
another superhero team up film take for
example the first special presentation
that we're going to talk about today
Ghost Writer Insider my time to shine
hello tweeted yesterday new Ghostwriter
solo project was in development
pre-strikes they will move forward with
it post strikes we have heard rumors
that a ghostwriter's special
presentation was in development for a
while now but now that an Insider is
confirming it it looks like this truly
is the case now many Marvel fans know
who Ghostwriter is in fact even if you
aren't a super big Marvel fan you most
likely know who he is thanks to the
Nicholas Cage adaptation of him however
he has not been introduced to the MCU
yet and that is what Marvel Studios and
Disney are going to use special
presentations for it's definitely a good
platform for introducing really big
characters who are going to impact the
MCU but don't necessarily need a six
episode long Disney Plus show or an
entire movie werewolf by night was
pretty dang close to perfect it was 53
minutes long it introduced us to the
character it showed us a lot of great
action sequences and actually introduced
us to a couple of more interesting
characters that are going to stick
around in the MCU so this will basically
be what is going to happen not only with
Ghost Rider but anybody else that they
chew used to introduce to the MCU for
the very first time in a special
presentation but Ghost Rider is a huge
one in fact all the ones that we're
going to talk about today are huge
there's no doubt that a supernatural
side of the MCU has already begun we
have one division doctor strange and the
Multiverse of Madness and of course
Agatha coven of chaos is coming up and
blade blade is going to be a big one for
the supernatural side and Ghost Rider
could pop up in Blade I'm not saying
this is confirmed or rumored but there
is a reason why they would be doing a
special presentation for Ghost Rider
because he is about to pop up in that
side of the MCU now we also know that
Marvel Studios does seem to be building
a midnight Suns team and Ghost Rider
definitely has to be a part of that we
also know and we'll talk about this as
the next special presentation as well
that Marvel Studios does plan on
introducing Mephisto to the MCU and in
fact the Fisto is kind of going to be
the big bad of the supernatural side so
that would definitely bring the midnight
Suns together but speaking of mephista
We Have Heard in the past that they were
developing a Mephisto special
presentation project now as far as we've
heard recently they might have changed
that a little bit deadline reported a
while ago that they believe Sasha bear
Cohen's character in ironheart is going
to be Mephisto that is what they said
and then the Insiders came out
afterwards and said that they basically
heard the same thing however recently
some have come out and stated that they
are really unsure about the state of
this project right now we do know
Mephisto is going to be popping up in
other projects though and we do know
that he is actually the person who
bought the old Avengers Tower from Tony
Stark so there's obviously a big story
that is going to be had with Mephisto in
the MCU the only question is is he going
to pop up in other shows and carry on
his story that way or will he get his
own special presentation if we hear any
updates about this specific one of
course we'll do an update video for you
but the next one is a character that
fans have been waiting for for a pretty
long time now and that is Nova and we've
heard a lot about Nova recently
unfortunately we've heard that this
project might be scrapped but there
might be some good news that comes with
that one we've heard that it's scrapped
because of the writers and actor strikes
which means once those are over of
course they could pick it back up much
like my time to shine hellos update on
The Ghost Writer special presentation
how they were working on it before and
plan to pick it back up again after the
strikes are over it could very well be
the same for Nova but we've also heard
that Marvel Studios has plans to
introduce him in movies as well so if
his special presentation is scrapped
it's probably due to the fact that they
have other plans for him in the MCU but
reports of him entering the MCU have
come out a lot from major trade
companies to insiders who have very good
track records they have all stated that
Nova is coming and we know that Marvel
Studios did have plans for a special
presentation for him so if we hear
anything about the specific project of
course we'll do an update now one thing
that we have heard about Nova is that
Marvel Studios was iron Ryan Gosling for
the role now it's interesting because
recently it said that Marvel Studios was
Ein Ryan Gosling to play Mr fan
fantastic of the Fantastic Four and both
could very well be true and let me
explain why Marvel Studios meets with
actors about a lot of possible roles
that they could play in the MCU they
don't necessarily always meet with these
actors for a specific role but simply
meet with them and say hey let's figure
out something that you could play in the
MCU because we want you in the MCU and
you want to be in the MCU so Kevin feige
could have met with Ryan Gosling about
Nova and about Mr Fantastic and possibly
about a lot of other roles as well but
the fact that many insiders have
reported that they've met with Ryan
Gosling about Nova and then met with him
about Mr Fantastic means that Kevin
wants him in the MCU and eventually he
probably will become a character I think
he would make a great Nova but let us
know what you think about that in the
comments down below now another one that
has been reported to be coming by
thecosmiccircus.com is a Silver Surfer
special presentation it's been said that
plans have changed for this as far as
when it's going to be coming but the
original report stated that it was going
to be coming before the Fantastic Four
movie which may makes sense because
we've heard that Galactus is going to be
the main villain of the Fantastic Four
film which means the Silver Surfer will
probably show up so to have a special
presentation before he shows up in the
Fantastic Four film to introduce him
would make a lot of sense plus Not only
would it introduce the Silver Surfer but
it would prepare people for Galactus it
would tell them who he is and why he is
such a huge threat for those who might
not know anything about Galactus after
all the last time we really got any
glimpse of him was in the Fantastic Four
film The Rise of the Silver Surfer where
he was a giant Cloud if we're not
counting what if and we haven't heard
anything recently about this special
presentation no longer happening so as
far as we're concerned that is still
their plan unless again the strikes
change things and we do know that the
schedule is going to be shifted a little
bit because of the strikes and last but
definitely not least one that I am super
excited for is Century a century special
presentation now we know that Sentry is
going to be appearing in the
Thunderbolts and there are some crazy
easy rumors going around that we won't
talk about in this video for spoiler
purposes but nonetheless I am super
excited for Century the man with the
power of a Million Suns he's supposed to
be making his debut in the Thunderbolts
however a special presentation planned
for him has been something that has been
reported for a while now but unlike the
other ones this one is supposedly going
to be after he's introduced to the MCU
which if we think about it kind of makes
sense because he is going to be
introduced in the Thunderbolts as a part
of a team I doubt they're really going
to go over the origin stories of
everybody since we've already seen the
origin stories of pretty much the entire
Thunderbolts team we've seen Yelena
belova story we've seen Red Guardian
story we know Taskmaster we know ghost
we know Bucky we know Zemo Etc the only
one that we really won't know the origin
story for is Sentry and I doubt they're
really going to go over it fully in the
Thunderbolts so it makes sense that
after that they would do a special
presentation showing us how he became
Sentry and Thunderbolts is taking place
immediately after the events of Captain
America Brave New World and we know both
projects are are going to talk about
super soldier serum and that is how he
gets his powers he gets a golden Century
serum which is basically a variation of
a super soldier serum just way more
enhanced but we know that that's going
to be a big thing in Captain America
Brave New World because Thunderbolt Ross
is going to be experimenting with serums
as well and he himself is even going to
become the Red Hulk so it all ties in
and it makes sense that they would
choose to do this special presentation
to show his origin after the events of
the Thunderbolts especially since people
will be pretty hype to see him in that
movie and be waiting for another project
with a minute so five really exciting
characters and five really exciting
special presentations are in store for
us in Marvel Studios on Disney plus let
us know how excited you are for these
characters to get their own special
presentations in the comments down below
and like I mentioned if we hear anything
in regards to updates on these
characters or shows we'll be sure to do
an update video so be sure to subscribe
and hit that notification Bell so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
videos please don't forget to like the
video and of course you can follow us on
Instagram and Twitter as well and as
always thank you all so much for
watching wolf